This is exactly what you did in Lesson 7, when you found where a sample mean
falls on the distribution of sample means. And then you used the z table to
find the probability that you'll select a sample mean greater than that value.
If you look in the z table for this z-score value, 2.44, you'll see that a
proportion of 0.9927 is less than that z-score. That means the proportion
greater than 2.44 is 1 minus 0.9927, which is 0.0073. If our sample mean falls
within the critical region, we then conclude that this mean comes from an
entirely different distribution. In other words, the treated population.
Another way to put it is that we believe that our treatment had an effect. Of
course, it is possible that we made a decision error. In other words, it's
possible that we should have kept the null hypotheses, that there is no
significant difference, and that the only reason we got this sample mean was
due to chance, because there's a 0.0073% chance that we get at least this
sample mean. However, the chances are small, less than our alpha level.
Therefore, we reject the null hypothesis. But again, we don't need to find the
probability of obtaining at least the sample mean. All we need to know is that
the z-score of the of the sample mean is greater than the z-critical value.
2.44 is greater than 1.96. That alone tells us that our sample mean landed in
the critical region and then we can reject the null.